dès le matin se promener dans les rues
c'était un véritable parcours du
combattant
toujours à deux doigts de la chute mais
à montréal il fallait être patient pour
le déglaçage et le déneigement
parce que la ville pratique la technique
de l'essuie-tout c'est qu'on utilise les
premiers centimètres de neige pour
absorber nos qu'on a reçues qui va créer
donc d'avoir une couche qui permet
d'absorber ensuite une mince couche de
glace qui nous permet à prayssas de
passer avec la gratte de ramasser cette
neige là et de sembler derrière les
opérations en attendant un peu partout
au québec ce sont désagréables pour
déloger cette croûte de verglas et
grattoir ont fonctionné à lui son canton
déneigement autour de la voiture c'est
le sport hivernal par excellence et en
équipe et faire du sport moi c'est
gratuit avec les chaussées glissantes la
circulation était ralentie mais ceux qui
s'occupent de la navette entre montréal
et québec en ont vu d'autres
on au poignet de l'appuyer de la neige
conditions hivernales de 4,1 de saint
jean dans un an comment dire la grande
question des parents ce matin des
centaines d'écoles allait-elle ouvrir
leurs portes en fait sa demande à une
réorganisation complète de notre matinée
certaines familles n'avaient pas reçu le
message ou voulait s'assurer que les
portes des écoles étaient bel et bien
close une vérification à en tomber à la
renverse à saguenay c'était un peu le
cafouillage avant de finalement
connaître la décision de fermer les
écoles les conditions se dégrader
rapidement
c'est quelque chose qui est évidemment
aux autres quatre heures plus tôt on
n'est pas capable de déterminer parce
que on la météo manie météorologues se
trompe parfois elle en tout cas face à
l'adversité hivernale au saguenay c'est
la solidarité qui prime le plaisir même
enfer de pousser ma voiture
on vient de montréal et on n'en voit pas
ça souvent bref de rimouski à trois
rivières on s'est accommodé à cet autre
caprice brutale de l'hiver j'ai réussi à
sortir de chez moi ça vaut bien pour
l'installateur de plus ce texte a vogué
dessus ben oui suis déçu je pensais que
j'allais oublier de rester coincé si
nous tous mes rendez vous était mieux
aujourd'hui
gmac une auto hoje rester à la maison
une tempête de surmonter
jusqu'à la prochaine fois ici frédéric
arnould radio canada montréal